Francia celebró con un magnánimo desfile
en su fiesta nacional este 14 de Julio
un desfile a lo largo de los campos
elíseos desfile que abrió el presidente
Manuel a bordo de un acmad un vehículo
que utilizan las fuerzas especiales
francesas Desde allí pues pasó en
revista las tropas y también a lo largo
de la recorrido esto le permitió saludar
a las miles de personas que estuvieron
presentes en este desfile para poder ver
todo este espectáculo que duró cerca de
dos horas un espectáculo no solamente de
muchísima precisión sino también con
muchísima música a lo largo de estas dos
horas el presidente Manuel estuvo en la
tribuna presidencial acompañado por su
esposa los miembros del gobierno la
alcaldesa de París Y por supuesto
nariandra modi el Primer Ministro de la
India el país invitado de honor a este
desfile 250 militares de ese país
desfilaron por los campos elíseos de
hecho una ceremonia que fue transmitida
en vivo y en directo en la televisión
pública de la India para que todos allá
en casa también pudieran ver este
desfile en el que participaron 6.500
personas en total unos 60 aviones 200
caballos todo esto para darles un orden
de ideas de digamos lo magnánimo de todo
este evento al término ya de todo este
desfile Manuel marco saludo a los
diferentes personas invitadas
especialmente a las familias de los
militares que murieron en el último año
en los diferentes terrenos de combate Y
por supuesto tanto macron como Mode y
continuarán con su agenda oficial en la
tarde de hoy con una declaración
conjunta ya en la tarde en el Eliseo y
esta noche una cena de gala que macron
ofrece a modi en el Museo de lujo